if you have to relieve yourself after a
full meal um maybe it's not Thanksgiving
maybe you're going on a romantic weekend
with someone for the first time I'm just
saying all these tips apply there
actually is this great little thing that
it's like an essential oil I'm
forgetting the name of it but you spray
oh Poo PooPourri and by the way she
became a billionaire from creating
PooPourri like clearly there's a market
need but if it's Thanksgiving like just
wait until you get home like you don't
want to embarrass yourself like that
long din din or just be honest we're all
family here girl I'll be right back I
got to unstuff my
turkey right
back